Pope Francis is summoning more than a
hundred bishops from across the world
for an unprecedented summit on
preventing clergy sex abuse the Vatican
hopes that Thursday's meeting will be a
turning point in efforts to protect
minors the Pope is face growing
criticism for his handling of the
church's sexual abuse crisis Seth Doane
is following the summit preparations is
outside the Vatican with more on this
story Seth good morning good morning
this summit is the first of its kind and
as part of the catholic church's
response to clerical sex abuse scandals
that have rocked the church from chile
to Australia to the United States so
Pope Francis is inviting the heads of
Bishops conferences from around the
world to the Vatican to try to
standardize the church's response to the
sexual abuse of minors one of the key
issues abuse survivors are hoping to see
progress on this week is holding bishops
accountable right now there are
protocols for punishing predator priests
but the higher level bishops can only be
investigated if authorized by the Pope
that is a loophole many here would like
to see closed what the US Church will
gain from this is a big question as
guidelines to protect minors have
already been in place since 2002 and
abuse survivors are playing a limited
role only 10 of them about 10 of them
will meet with organizers tomorrow on
the eve of the summit the organizers of
this summit have already been
downplaying the expectations of what can
be achieved this week saying that
follow-up is key Nora
that is true the fall will be watching
that closely Seth Doane in Rome thank
you